let's move on to Jennifer Lawrence now
okay this lady has been all over the
globe promoting her new movie and
wherever Jim goes it seems like our
Cameron Madison is sure to follow he's
in New York with her today and cam
listen I am freaked out just by previews
of this movie yeah Michelle her new
movie mother definitely is not for the
faint of heart I can tell you that
firsthand but apparently it's also true
when it comes to her own family I'm
nervous I have one brother that I know
is gonna walk out he's seen it yeah he
can't watch Willy Wonka cause of Oompa
Loompas he you couldn't even watch the
trailer Jennifer knows just how her
brother feels even she freaked out the
first time she saw her disturbing new
thriller about a marriage jolted by
uninvited houseguests did you know he
had a wife and when she was making the
movie she shook off its creepy intensity
by binging on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians in a private tent what why
not a housewives tip the Kardashians are
more comforting to me I think I've been
watching them for like 11 years so I
grew up with them I know all of them
personally I feel like if I walked into
a 10 of the housewives I'd be like ah
God LuAnn what are you doing Ramona shut
up opening in theaters Friday the movie
was directed by Jennifer's boyfriend of
one year Oscar nominee Darren Aronofsky
who sweetly calls her the Michael Jordan
of acting who would you compare him to
I don't really know athletes whose ass
granny this granny adorable athlete
reality star because I know you know
reality TV oh that's not fair cuz most
of most reality TV stars are mentally
compromised
you